This program is being presented to you
by the Heras International Winter School
on Gravity and Light.
[Music]
So, good morning and welcome to the 11th
lecture. Today's topic is symmetry, but
in fact, we'll pick up a number of
elementary techniques in differential
geometry that we will need urgently in
Einstein's theory. But I will motivate
these techniques uh by appealing to your
feeling to your intuition.
Namely the feeling uh that the so-called
round sphere
and you remember
that
the round sphere was first of all a
smooth manifold
which at that stage cannot be said to
have shape but as the at the moment we
provide a specific metric and I gave a
metric last time uh which we call the
round metric G round
uh that that is an object that um has
properties that follow our intuition of
shape. Uh we have the feeling that the
round sphere as defined last time uh has
rotational symmetry.
So if I provide you with an example of
such a round sphere and then you can
turn it around as you wish and it looked
the same in any after any transformation
of turning it around has rotational
symmetry while and that's an a crucial
point uh while the potato
uh which is also S2A
as a smooth manifold old but has been
equipped with a different metric and it
depends on where you buy your potatoes.
Uh but there may be different potatoes.
Uh but let's call that the potato
metric. Uh while the potato does not
feature that symmetry.
Now this all seems simple enough but in
fact it's quite different from the ideas
of symmetry especially rotational
symmetry but also other symmetries we're
going to talk about
different from how you thought of them
so far because so far you probably
thought of rotational symmetries as some
SO3 group in whatever at whatever level
of sophistication
where you demand and we uh tell our
students that you need an inner product
first and then with respect to that
inner product you can classify linear
maps A such that A acting on a vector X
and A acting on a vector Y taking the
inner product reproduces XY. So these
are um linear transformations in a
vector space that respect an inner
product. Now here we're talking about
something different altogether.
Nevertheless, it's the same idea.
up to this up to here there is no metric
there is no inner product and first of
all second once you have a metric we
talk about the symmetry of the metric
itself because the only thing that
distinguishes these two objects is the
metric so the symmetry is a property of
the metric and not given a metric you
have additional transformations that
respect something that's the first
difference is um well a metric provides
you with an inner product in each
tangent space, but that's certainly not
going to be the the inner product
because there are many inner products
and many different tangent spaces that
can be used to redefine SO3 with respect
to some of the tangent spaces. But this
is talking about the distribution of
these inner products over the sphere in
this case, right? And that the
distribution is in some sense rotational
invariant or not. So we really have to
think about this in a slightly different
way and we need a number of techniques
uh to do that and that will be of
crucial importance. So um the question
is uh uh how to describe symmetries
how to describe symmetries
of a metric
and this is not an academic question.
It's a question of the utmost importance
when finding or trying to find solutions
to Einstein's equations because nobody
can solve Einstein's equations without
additional assumptions on for instance
the symmetry of the solution but in many
physical situations you know about such
symmetries or you postulate them and
then you make progress. So this is
technically very important in order to
speak of these symmetries. Um there are
a number of technical concepts we need
that are also very useful in other
places. Amongst them are some points I
left out in the course so far. So
several loose ends will be collected
this morning. So the first thing we want
to look at uh are is the push forward
map.
Now what is this? Um let's take two
smooth manifolds. So there's no metric
yet. So this is a smooth manifold. This
is a smooth manifold. And let's consider
between the two smooth manifolds a
smooth map fi.
Then we define the following map that's
induced by this map fi. So we send
points to points in a manifold. Uh then
the push forward
map the push forward has a name. It's
named like this map from which it's
derived but uh it has a little star
downstairs. The push forward fi star is
the map. What map is it? It's a map that
takes an element
of the tangent bundle of M. What does
that mean? Well, some vector to M at
some point. That's an element of the
tension bundle and takes it to an
element of the tangent bundle of this
manifold.
So if this is underlying on the base
manifold, this guy is up there. So if
you wish you can complete this picture
like this that uh you know that you have
the bundle maps here uh this one and
here you have the other projection the
tension bundle here to the base space
and the map fi by which we started the
game is down here and this one acts up
here and from this one we induce this
one how
defined by
well I take an element of the tangent
bundle as promised and I send it to si
star of x which is supposed to be an
element here but I now need to tell you
how where well if phi star of x is an
element in here right you agree it can
act on a function f that's defined down
here because then an element in here is
a vector on this manifold. A vector on
this manifold can act on a function on
that manifold. Right?
So we can let it act on any function f
where any f a smooth function on the
target manifold. We have that five star
x acts on f as the x which is a vector
here on this manifold right how the x
acts on f after phi. So nothing really
happened. I I take a vector here on a
vector to this tangent space. I send to
a tangent space here. I send it to a
vector to a tension space there such
that this acts on that like this vector
would have acted on the composition of
these two. It's a very natural it's a
very natural construction.
This is the push forward of the map fi.
And um note from this construction uh of
this f after fi you can see that if you
apply the push forward
to a fiber here you can take an entire
fiber here. So here you have your base
manifold M there you have the tension
bundle say like this and at the point P
you have the TPM. You remember now if
you take here an entire fiber over a
point P
then the result you send every point of
that the result is the fiber or at least
lies in the fiber be careful lies in the
fiber PH of P
over N because the base point of this
vector is mapped to the base point five
of P and lies in the fiber
over there. That's the push forward of a
map. And there is a
uh little minnemonic
in order to remember what the push
forward is because you will also define
the pull back in a second. And the push
forward you remember by vectors are
pushed forward.
vectors are pushed forward. Okay. So
this is just a map that has been defined
and um maybe uh it's less mystic if we
consider it in a chart
um the components
of phi star in and now I said in a chart
well that's not quite convincing because
the whole business happens on two
different between two different
manifolds. So components of five star
with respect to two charts,
namely one chart ux uh of in the atlas
of M and one chart VY in the atlas of N.
And these might be totally different
manifolds, different dimension and so
on. But nevertheless uh this fi
star can act on an element of the
tangent bundle here. So it certainly can
act on d by
dx i.
Okay, because that's an element of the
tangent bundle. If you want you can let
it act on one at a particular point.
This is clearly an element of the
tangent bundle. Okay. And uh then you
get an element here. But this you
extract the i the j component or let me
call this the eth component. You extract
by applying the dual base here. And uh
so these guys you will call
as always
star up a down i. But be careful uh this
I here now runs from one to dim M and
this A here runs from
one to dim N.
So these are not tensor components
because these refer to different tension
spaces not even at different points that
as well but even in different manifolds.
Okay. So these are components of this uh
of the induced linear map in these
between these tangent spaces. Um uh but
anyway uh we it's useful to to write
them down. So let's apply the
definition. So what is the push forward
of this? Well we need a function there
but we have the dy in front. So first of
all this is a vector. So it can act dya
acts on a vector like the vector acts on
the function. So this is d by dxi
at a point p
vector acting on the y a that's the
definition of the d
definition of the d. Now once you have
that you use the definition from over
there. This is this acts like this
vector I'm mapping at the point p acts
on y a after the underlying ph. That's
the definition
of five star as we just made it. Okay.
And if you now look at this little
diagram here, um ah we haven't got a
diagram yet. Uh so I have the M. I have
a chart U of M.
Uh I have a chart V of N. The U went
with an X map. The V with a Y map. I
have X of U. And I have Y of U. This may
be an RD and this may be an RC. Okay.
And from here to here we have the
restriction of the F map here. And um so
what I have here down here that's the
charge representation of the FH map. Y
after five after X inverse but what I
have here
this guy here Y After
Fi I can pull the A out. That's of
course the same thing. This y after phi,
this is this diagonal map. And let's
call this phi hat. So I could write this
here as d fi hat a component by d x i at
position p.
So the components
of this push forward are simply
calculated like this with the use of our
symbol. is a very simple thing to
implement in practice by this
calculation having chosen charts. The
important thing here is the construction
and what it yields us. Now let me give
you a picture for what the push forward
does.
It's really a very natural thing
picture. So imagine we have a manifold
M. That's the one we start from here.
and a manifold n and between them you
have a map that takes points here to
points there and the map is called phi.
So this is the point ph of p. So you see
we go back to the beginning in the
formalism we have a map taking points to
points from one manifold to another. Now
in order to understand the push forward
map better it's a clever idea to look at
a certain curve
here look at the curve gamma h so uh
gamma is just some curve
in the manifold m smooth smooth
so aha so if you have a curve and the
curve runs through a point what can you
write down well of course you can write
down the tangent vector to this curve
curve in this point. You know, I
shouldn't draw it like an arrow, but I
do draw it as an arrow. But just in
order to say we're talking about the
tangent vector, but you know that the
tangent vector
to the curve is not an arrow. You know
the tangent vector to the curve is a map
which at this point which is defined at
this point. I remind you it's a map from
here to there and it's a linear map.
It's the directional derivative. Okay.
So you have that if you have a curve.
Now what does the push forward do? It's
very simple. The push forward can map
the entire curve. So the claim is that
if this is the
if you map every point of the curve then
you get the curve phi
after gamma.
Right? Fi after gamma is the image of
this curve under the map fi here.
Okay. And now the very simple and very
clear statement is this is what happens
to the points is described by the map
fi. What happens to the blue tangent
vector is described by
the push forward the push forward of
this curve of this tangent vector is
this vector here. So um claim
right claim
the push forward of the tangent vector
to the original curve in the point p
is the tangent vector to the curve phi
after gamma to the pushed forward curve
by the map phi in the point ph of p. So
the push forward pushes tangent vectors
of curves to tangent vectors of the
pushed forward curves. Yes, I can can
imagine this if m and n have the same
dimension. Yes, they have different
dimensions. So then the the map can be
active or bactive. So so the dimension
of the resulting curve may be even
different. Yes. No. Um the the point is
particularly interesting is
the following if the n has a smaller
dimension than the m. So we do it like
this and um and this is an injective map
because if this is an injective map that
means you can think now I draw a big
space three-dimensional it's not the
space I mean the interior of this is
just to get an idea and I could take a
two uh dimensional thing like R2
and I take so this is N and this is M
but I need to prescribe to you how I put
this one into here and I may by choice
of this fi choose to put it in like
this.
Okay, so it's in there like that. It is
R2 as a manifold as a smooth manifold
and I put it in here. Now the point is
if you know in here you have a tangent
vector to a curve in this smooth
manifold. This is a two-dimensional
object because it's in a two-dimensional
and so on and so on. But once you
embedded it, you may ask okay the object
that was tangent here. Let me draw
another embedding in order to make a
better picture. But you see the idea. So
uh say
it's a little bit embedded like
like this. So it goes on like this. say
I embedded such that you get a little uh
uh hemisphere here. Um
now the point is if this point here is
say being mapped to this point here and
the curve now runs through here uh this
tangent vector will be mapped to a
tangent vector that's now a tangent
vector of here but it's actually the
same tangent vector. So you you can
consider a tangent vector to to
something like this. You can consider it
an intrinsic tangent vector to this guy.
That's a two-dimensional vector in
quotation marks. Or you can consider it
a tangent vector to this thing in the
bigger space which is then a
three-dimensional vector. You see my
point? And this push forward effects
exactly that. So a push forward converts
intrinsic tangent vectors to exttrinsic
tangent vectors. If this is an embedding
map, which it is if it's smooth and
injective,
it's a different perspective on twice
the same object. Right? So this is the
velocity the ant would talk about who
doesn't know anything about the third
dimension. This is the velocity you
would talk about seeing an ant running
along in three space. Okay. Um that is
what the ant can do. That's what you can
do. And and the push forward pushes this
to there. That's one application for
this special case. Another application
will be it's the same manifold. We'll
come to that. So it has many
applications.
Okay.
So uh that's what it does. Um now the um
we should prove that this is true. Um
this is not too difficult to prove that
this is true.
So how does that work? So we calculate
phi star of v gamma p. This is a vector
tangent to this. I need to let it act on
a function where fun f is a function on
the target here.
What is this? Well, how is it is how is
it defined? It's defined as the action
of the vector. So it's the definition of
phi star action of the vector on uh f
after phi.
Correct? That's what we uh wrote down
there. Um but now what's the definition
of the tangent vector? You see it's
always the same stuff. Definition of the
tangent vector is it's the um derivative
of the function here f after phi after
the curve. we're talking about in the
point at which we go through the curve.
So let's say this be lambda 0. So let's
say that gamma at lambda 0 traverses p.
Okay, that's the point p we're talking
about. But now I clearly have
associivity
of the composition. So I can write it
like this. And this is clearly the
velocity of this curve at the point phi
of gamma not zero lambda 0
but that's five of p acting on the
function f and this is true for any such
function f. Hence you know that this guy
is this guy.
End of proof. very simple and very
powerful because you have a very clear
geometric picture of what that actually
means.
Okay,
this guy the push forward has a sibling.
The sibling of the push forward is
called the pull back.
What is the pull back definition?
We again have a map fi that smoothly
goes from one manifold
smooth manifold in another smooth
manifold.
And now we go the opposite way. We
induce another map which is called five
upstar
but its domain is now the co-angent
bundle but not of the space of the
domain of phi
not of the domain of phi but of the
target of phi. So this is an m and this
is an n. And now this really goes from
the co-angent bundle of the target into
the tangent co-angent bundle of the
domain. Hence it's called pull back
because you go the opposite direction if
you act on elements of the cotangent
bundle. So if you act on forms. So how
is this supposed to act? Well, omega a
form uh sorry a co- vector is sent to
phi upstar
omega and the result is supposed to lie
in here. Well, how can I then specify
this result where phi star of omega
lying in here must be able to take a
vector
from here. So I should maybe color code
this as well.
can take you take a form from here from
here. Hang on. Now I'm confused. You
take exactly the wrong way around.
Sorry. Um you take a form here
and you take a vector
here. So that's it. Yes. Yes. So you
take a form here, take a vector here.
And how do you define this? Well, you
define this by using the push forward.
So, you define the pull back, but you
use the push forward. So, careful. Uh,
index up.
And here we have index down.
Up is the pull back. Down is the push
forward. You need to be careful here.
You push forward the vector. What else?
Because vectors are pushed forward. uh
and then you have a vector in tangent to
this a co- vector here.
So then you apply that co- vector and
that defines your result.
Now
components of the pullback
with respect to charts plural
and you already know why because we're
dealing with two manifolds. We're
dealing with several charts and there's
a little surprise surprise.
So we do the push the pull back sorry of
the pullback. Yeah, you do the pull back
of now we chose charts before. I think
we chose ux in the atlas of m and vy in
the atlas of n. Is that right? I think
we did this way. And so now you can pull
back a co- vector on here. So you need
can pull back the basis of the chart
induced co- vectors here
at some point five of p. You take this
and you pull it back and then you get a
vector to to x. But if it's a vector
to x, hang on a second. You then get a
form. You get a form on the manifold.
But a form can then act on a vector
that's d by dx
i. And I think here we chose components
a. Is that right? So let's keep the same
convention and we take this at the point
P because you pull back the form to the
point P if the form here was at five of
P. Well, let's evaluate this. So this is
what you would call in linear algebra
the components, namely the AI component
of the pullback. Now the stars up before
the star was down. Well, we plug this
all in. But this is by definition. Look
at here. You need to take the form
that's this one dya and you apply it to
the push forward that's now the phi down
of the d by dxi at the point p. But if
you inspect this carefully this is
exactly what of course defines the
component
ai of the push forward index down
not index star down
star up. So what do you see? The
components of the pullback are exactly
the same as the components of the push
forward.
That's good. So if you have to calculate
push forwards and pull backs in in
charts, you choose them. You calculate
these components once and it just
depends on how you use them. Whether you
later on contract with this index or
whether you contract with that index
means you do a push forward or a pull
back. Okay. So um you can write down the
push forward of a vector and you will
have its eighth comp its eighth
component.
You will have it by looking at the push
forward a iix x i. But you can do the
pullback of a form and you have its i
component because it lands in the other
space. This is phi
a i and the omega has an index a down
here. So you see but these two guys
numerically they're the same. So you
calculate them once and depending on
what index you contract with you get one
or the other map in charts. Okay.
Right.
And I remind you this was just a
reminder this was if you take this map
that takes you from here to there and
you take this diagonal representation
it's this guy.
Okay. So push forward and pull back. And
you have an equally
uh appealing picture for the pullback
picture. What does it do? Well, you
already guessed it. Now you're not
talking about curves. Now you're talking
about having a function here and these
are the level lines of a function f
right like temperature the isootherms
right and you have a map that takes you
from here to here and say the map is
such that
it would take this here to that here. It
would spread them apart. Then you could
definitely talk about the gradient of f
over there.
But that's a cove vector field or a
cove. Yeah. Co- vector field. a core
vector uh you can take it and you can
pull it back. Okay. Uh and it should be
what? It should be the gradient of the
function uh f after phi.
Yes. And then this these here are the
level lines for f after five. Okay. And
you show this in the tutorials.
Yes.
Does it make it sense to ask whether the
push forward and the pull back are
somehow inverse to each other?
No, you can see it on the interesting
question but you see it on their uh uh
on their on their domains. So the push
forward takes you from tm to tn and um
so that's this direction.
Now the pullback takes you from t star n
back to t star m. Uh but none of these
four spaces are the same. So how would
well somehow some an inverse is you go
the opposite way.
I mean
you mean if you uh if you make a link
here
inverse joint and and how is it defined?
Why why is it adjint?
Yes.
Well, yes. That is um so you you're
talking about if you have V to W fi uh
then you can do the dual map or whatever
you call it. You mean this? Yes, it's
the adjoin map but the point is that's
exactly the difference between the two.
Um but it's not like one is the inverse
of the other. Yeah, that's right. That's
right. So this is the Okay, forget this.
But this is the linear algebra uh analog
analog. Okay.
Um right. So we have the the pullback of
forms. So what you should remember is so
the minimmonic phrase
before we had vectors are pushed forward
and now we have co- vectors
co- vectors are pulled back.
So again you have a manifold and another
manifold and you have a map that takes
points to points. You can take a vector
here and using this these data you can
bring it here by the push forward and
you can use a co- vector on here and
using this data in this direction you
can take it here by the pull back. But
if you have a vector here generically
you will not be able to pull it back.
And if you have a co- vector on here,
generically you will not be able to push
it forward using these data. Of course,
if phi is invertible,
meaning there is a phi inverse, of
course, I can now take a co- vector here
and bring it here because I just pull
the omega form back to here along the
inverse. Okay, so
these rules are only applicable or only
are so tight if this fi is not
necessarily invertible. That was the
question that g asked. What if this is
smaller than this? Then it can't be
invertible. Right? Okay. So this is the
push forward and the pull back of vector
fields and forms respectively. And now
we have an important application.
Did it deserve its own section number?
No, it didn't.
Well, you know that the vectors and the
co- vectors are our building blocks and
once we understand them, we understand a
lot. So, let's say we have here that's
the situation I alluded to before. we
have an injective map fi for instance
the dimension of m is lesser than the
than the dimension of n and then this
corresponds to embedding one manifold
into the other. Okay. So for instance,
yeah well um so now once we have that
now imagine you have on this bigger
manifold on the space around the
embedded one uh you have a metric
say on this space lives a metric G
question if you know the metric in the
space around can you induce a metric on
here or um assume I'm in R3 so example I
do an example alongside let's say n
equals u r3 and we equip it with the
standard topology and the smooth atlas
and whatn not okay so let's say this
space is that and let's assume m is s2 o
a then we can certainly find many maps
phi that take our m or s2 into r3
right and it depends on fi how it lies
in there. So for instance it could lie
in there like this but it could also lie
in there
like the potato does right still there
is no shape this is just how this one
lies in here but still you don't know
what shape is but if on R3 you use a
metric for instance the ukidian metric
that we all know that in a special in
the identity chart is 111 with
components The question is can I take
the ukidian metric out here and can I
inherit it to this surface or if I embed
it otherwise. So this is with one file
map this is with another file map. If I
embed it otherwise I will probably get a
different metric if I pull back. The
question is which one would I like to
take? It's very simple
here. I take a string and I stretch it.
So it's it's maximal elongation and this
has a length. I have a length measure
for curves, not for vectors but for
curves in in here. And then if I want to
measure the sphere, I take this string
and I put it on the sphere. And of
course it will span over part of the
sphere like this. And I will say I want
a metric such that if I finally
calculate the length of this curve, it
should be the length I would take of the
string in R3. That's how we induce a
metric. And um the induced metric
then the induced
metric G sigma that's then the metric
that lives in here
uh G sigma GM
GM that's the metric that's induced from
this metric using the embedding
this will eat vectors X and Y where well
in here so this will each vectors in
each tangent space of M. Okay.
And this is defined as the metric over
here. Excellent. I have it. But I need
to somehow translate the vectors I
attach to here to vectors over there in
order to feed them into this metric. How
would you do that?
By using the push. The push forward of
course. And that depends on the
embedding map how that looks like. So
the embedding will matter for the
result.
That's it. That's it. That's the induced
metric. Now of course you can write it
down in components and then you use
twice the push forward map components
from over here. So in components right
you can write G. Now the chart over
there I think was with AB indices right
instead of J indices. And then you have
phi hat I defined a by dx i at the point
p. This is taken at the point p times d
fi hat b dxj at the point p. And those
are then the components of g m i j.
Well, that's not quite right. This is at
the point five of p. I'm sorry. That's
at the point five of p.
because here we're at the point P.
And this formula you probably used
before. This is how if you have an
embedding map, you take the
differentials and blah blah blah blah
and you get the metric on the smaller
space. And in the tutorials you will
learn and you will do this in practice
uh that if you take this embedding
rather than this one and you calculate
this guy that this is the round metric.
So if fi is this embedding that takes
the sphere into r3 like this then the
metric you inherit is the round metric
that I always just wrote down and I
didn't say where it comes from. But
again, if you have the uklidometric out
here and you have, you know, the
embedding function for instance, that's
also being done in the tutorials. You
embed it like this. That's also the S2,
but we would call it the ellipsoid, but
we can't call the ellipsoid yet before
we didn't induce a metric. Okay, but
it's embedded like this. If you pull
that back, you get a different metric.
But these are all metrics on S2 S2A.
Okay, so the shape lies in the metric.
And that is how you can get new metrics
on so-called embedded submanifolds. If
you have a metric outside, the basic
technique is to push forward of the
tension vector fields. It's all very
simple.
[Music]
Yes, that's right. That's possible.
Well, try to define it. The inverse
metric over here
eats co- vectors. You can define the
metric here by providing co- vectors
here. The inverse metric here by
defining co- vectors which you pull back
from the co- vectors over there.
Pardon me.
TPN.
Well, yes. This is point by point. So
this is on the to whole uh as I said
these these um push forward and pull
back are on the whole tangent bundle at
any point you can take any vector and
send it back and forth.
No no no no that's something different
that's if you want to map fields to
fields so that a section remains a
section.
Okay.
Right. So we learn something really
interesting because it gives some
substance to some arbitrary seemingly
arbitrary examples I wrote down before
still has nothing to do with symmetry
because this is just stuff we also need
for symmetry but it would be a shame to
pass by without mentioning it.
Yes,
the analogy that I take the string and I
pull it and maximum elongation I put it
on something and about this maximum
elongation how do you know around which
path you have this maximum elongation
there was the quick picture not so quick
picture is I measure curves in the
ambient space
by measuring their tangent vectors
now I take a curve
I embed it and the curve has an image.
That's what we did before. And the
tangents to the curves are pushed over
here. So I take a curve in the sphere
and then I take this and that's
abstract. I then embed the sphere and
the curve was formally on the sphere
becomes now a curve in R3 by pushing the
curve forward. Now in R3 it lies like
this. Say and now I measure it with the
metric in R3 because its tangent vectors
now stand here. I measure this and
because we know that the tangents to
curves go to tangents to curves this
works. This this shows by our way of
thinking about the length of curves that
this is exactly what I described before.
So it's no mystery that this reproduces
the metric as we know it.
I'm sorry I need to use this this thing
because of my throat. Sorry. Okay.
Now we come closer to the symmetry stuff
with lots of more important and
interesting things. Flow of a vector
field.
Well, flow of a complete vector field.
So we take now throughout a manifold MOA
that's smooth
and we take um X to be a vector field.
vector field on the smooth manifold.
And the first notion we need is that of
an integral curve. Very simple notion.
Definition. A curve
gamma.
Well, from some interval that lies in
the real numbers of course into the
manifold, a curve is called an integral
curve.
an integral curve of x of this vector
field x if and that's a condition as it
couldn't be simpler. If the tangent
vector to the curve at each point of the
curve
reproduces the already given vector
at the point where you are. It's a very
simple concept. So you have a smooth
picture.
You have a smooth vector field.
Okay, you have a smooth vector field.
And now an integral curve. The question
is, is this
an integral curve? This curve gamma. The
answer is no. Because its tangent
vectors, again I shouldn't draw the
vectors, but you know what I mean. The
tangent vectors do not coincide. Is the
um violet curve a an integral curve?
Yes, it is because its tangent vector
well almost tangent vector everywhere
agrees with the vector field. Very
simple notion.
Okay, that's an integral curve. And of
course uh you may think of this
you can think of the vector field as the
velocity
of water molecules in a river.
And then the gamma is of course the
trajectory of a ship,
maybe a paper ship that you throw in
that has no propulsion and that just
flows with it. Okay, so that's an
integral curve of a smooth vector field.
Um
yes.
Now um
definition
a vector field X
is set to be complete.
If integral curves, if all integral
curves,
obviously there are several integral
curves.
If all integral curves
have as their domain I the entire real
line of real numbers.
Example,
consider a smooth vector field.
So it goes like this
and so on. Now let's look at some
integral curves. So any curve goes
through through a point. So let's take
this one. Uh this will be an integral
curve. You agree? This is an integral
curve.
To what
domain can I extend the interval of its
parameter?
Well, arbitrary. It can go around and
around and around and it can come from
minus infinity.
Now, what about this point here
where the vector field vanishes?
Well, that's the constant function that
for any parameter value yields zero.
Also has I equals R. So this is a
complete vector field up to the point
when I viciously viciously
remove this point from the space.
Remove this point
from the space.
Why wouldn't I do that? I just take this
one out the manifold. Then this vector
doesn't exist. Of course, right next to
it, the next vector again exists. But I
take this one out viciously
and all of a sudden
this integral curve
comes to a certain stop because it comes
arbitrarily close to this point but it
won't just reach it because it's not
there.
So the vector field on this space the
same vector field without this point is
incomplete. So it's not the vector field
that misses a vector because then it
wouldn't be a vector field. Have to
remove the point from the space.
In spac-time physics,
we have many points so-called
singularities
which do not belong to the space-time
manifold. For instance, because the
curvature blows up, the curve the point
cannot be there. But that's not the only
points that cannot be there. And
actually the Hawking Penrose singularity
theorems were proven for singularities
that were defined in this or similar
manner depending on what you want to do
with geodessics and not
singularities are points where curves
stop
at finite parameter value and that is
the technical
door to singularity theorems. Okay. I
mean very roughly I'm talking here of
the zeroth order contribution to the
definition but that's that's the basic
idea. So the completeness of vector
fields is a very important point. Yes.
Yeah.
I can just if I have a doain I can
restrict it. Yeah. But then it doesn't
have the domain anymore. Yeah. But then
it doesn't have the domain anymore. The
question is is this domain all of R? The
point is you cannot reparameterize
because you see because the given vector
field X forces you to have a certain
parameterization to produce exactly that
velocity not double as long or not half
as long
that was your question right so you you
couldn't say well let's go there very
slowly slowly slowly in parameter okay
clear yes if we have compact manifold
yes the vector vector field will be
complete that's There's a theorem
theorem a compactly supported vector
field
smooth
vector field
is complete.
Yes, this is not compact if you take
this point out. Okay. And compact is a
topological notion.
Any open cover has a finite subcover.
whatever that means. Anyway, so that's
the definition is a topological notion.
It refers to the topology. Okay, good.
So I introduced this first of all
because of this little illusion to
singularity theorems. Uh but most
importantly in order to define the
following to define the key notion of
flow of a vector field. Definition.
The flow
of a vector field
X
is a one parameter family.
Is a one parameter family.
Um and the one parameter family has the
name H upx.
H like flow. I don't know. So anyway, H
is the traditional letter here. The flow
of the vector field X. The one parameter
family is you give a real parameter R.
Ah, the flow of a complete vector field.
There we go.
The flow of a complete vector field. And
now you see I need this in a second. And
it takes
a lambda, a number and a point in a
manifold m and sends that point in the
manifold m with the help of this number
to another point in the same manifold
because we have a vector field x on one
manifold. There's only one manifold in
the game right now. How does it do that?
Well, it takes a point and it gives you
a little lambda and sends it to the
point gamma subpa.
What is that?
where
gamma subp
defined on all r to m
is not it's not an integral curve. It's
the integral curve
of the vector flit x with
gamma of 0 equals p.
I can always do that. So I have a vector
field,
a smooth vector field.
Okay. And what does the this map do?
This map takes an arbitrary point. Let's
say this one. And of course at every
point there's a vector and it now
constructs an integral curve
that has at that starts at this point.
If the parameter lambda is zero and
takes you so that's the integral curve
and after a certain parameter value
lambda has passed you have gone from p
to gamma p of lambda agree
and this can now be written hx of lambda
comma p.
You think this is a little advanced if
you can rewrite it. But of course the
idea is you can now look at any point
here and this hx just requires
specification of this lambda and it's
tradition to denote the lambda down.
Well it it eats two things but the first
entry is denoted here and the second
entry will be denoted here. That's
tradition. So you can now look at h
lambda x of p.
Thus we have a map for fixed lambda. So
if you choose one lambda,
you can look at hx lambda. That's then
only a map from m to m and it will be a
smooth map.
And what is this?
It takes every point of the manifold and
pushes it further for a parameter
distance lambda according to the
integral curves of the field. So um
picture
this guy tells you um
well what is this who is that with
nobody you never enter the same river
twice. Who said that?
Tell me
heracit. Heraclit. Heraclit.
Did you say that? I Yes. Yes. So, okay.
Uh you never uh uh jump in the same
river twice. Uh the idea is you you take
the points, you take some set, okay, and
you push it forward. Well, now yeah, you
push the points forward along the smooth
map. You don't push forward vectors in
this case. you push forward points which
just means this can be taken as a
particular instance of our map f before
because the map from a manifold into
itself is a special case from before
right and in general this will not be
that set right so you take have the
river and you take a set and then you
wait for a parameter distance or
parameter time whatever lambda and then
that set has evolved into this that
for instance if the river flows apart
okay and so this is Heraclitz theorem if
you wish okay
well if the river is flowing if the
vector field is not zero
okay
now this is a very important
concept because it takes us closer to
understanding what happens on the
sphere. How have we used metrics so far
in this flow business? Not at all. We
have a smooth manifold. We have ve a
vector field given. Okay. Somehow
somebody gave us a vector field and we
can flow along the vector field. Okay.
Now take the sphere I gave you. Think of
it not as the sphere with a metric. But
just think of it as the potato. I give
you could give you a vector field on the
potato like this. I could give you one
like this and one like that. Yeah.
Around all in intuitively around all
possible axes, but there are no axes.
Could give you many many many different
vector fields right on the sphere or on
the potato. also on the smooth manifold
and I could ask if I push the points
forward like this if I let the points
flow I can look at the induced push
forward of vectors
or the pull back of co- vectors or the
induced metric that I have then I let it
flow and then I look what the resulting
induced metric is if it hasn't changed
the metric was symmetric
if you do something and doesn't change
it's symmetric I write this down
precisely okay but these flows are the
key to understanding what happens if you
move on things but of course how would I
then talk about spherical symmetry
rather than cylindrical symmetry rather
than translational symmetry how do I
distinguish the symmetries
um well that's very simple
section four
le subal algebbras
of the algebra of the Lee algebra of
vector fields
of the Lee algebra gamma tma
bracket of vector fields.
This will make contact with a lot of
stuff you know.
So the first thing we look at we look at
the set of all vector fields. I just
remind you that was the set of all
vector fields.
And we saw that I can multi I can add
vector fields and I can multiply them by
a C infinity function. So we said this
guy was a C infinity M module.
However,
okay, full stop. That's this. Now, you
can also of course restrict yourself
to consider it an R vector space,
but then of course you no longer have a
finite basis for it, if you have a basis
at all, but you need many many vector
fields to produce all the other vector
fields. But that's not the point here.
The point is that if you have two vector
fields X and Y, you can calculate the
commutator. The commutator will again be
in this space.
What is this commutator? Well, it was
defined as XY if it's supposed to be a
vector field, it must be able to act on
a function and it acts like this.
You remember that's a vector field
again. Now it's an anti-ymmetric bracket
right? So you have uh x comma y is y
comma x uh it's r linear. So if you take
lambda x + z comma y is lambda but only
for real numbers x comma y + z comma y
and third
it satisfies the so-called
um Jacobe identity. So you can take x
comma y comma z. So you fill the second
slot again with the result of a bracket
and then you can do this three times
and cyclically rotate what's inside the
brackets.
So it's xyz, it's x y z, it's x y z and
the result will be zero. You can check
this
any vector space, well actually also any
module over a commutative ring, but any
vector space with such a map that takes
two of these guys to another of these
guys that is anti-ymmetric
are linear in each of the slots and
satisfies this rule. Any such structure
is called
a le algebra.
called a lee algebra and obviously all
the vector fields on a manifold
constitute a huge a massively huge lee
algebra namely if I consider this as an
R vector space it's an infinite
dimensional le algebra all the possible
vector spaces uh vector fields
but in a step b we now consider the
following
Let
x1 to xs
be s vector fields as many. So funny
English as many. So the number of vector
fields is s S vector fields
on m
but not just any but such that
if you take the commutator of one
with another so i and j run from one to
s
then you do not get a vector field that
cannot be written as a linear
combination of those but assume and that
is the such that that the result can
again be written as a linear combination
with real numbers of these vector fields
and so you need expansion coefficient CK
but it will depend on the I and the J.
So it has three indices
where these guys are real numbers so not
functions but real numbers and these
guys are called the structure constants
of what? Well, the definition is that
the span, so if you generate by factors
that are
um real numbers, if you generate linear
combinations of these guys, you
obviously get a sub vector space of
gamma tm
and the bracket that you inherit. So
they take the same bracket but this
bracket will not lead you outside this
space but will keep you inside this
space. Okay. So this span you can then
call for instance L and depends on this
choice. Okay. And these are the
structure constants of this guy. And
this is then a le subalgebra.
Would be more logical to call it a subly
algebra, but language demands a le subal
algebra.
So this is an infinite dimensional le
algebra of all the vector fields. And
now we pick a few that close. And there
are many such choices many many many
choices of subal algebbras. The
interesting thing is example
you know special cases for instance
assume so these are vector fields on say
s2
assume you take vector fields three
vector fields x1 x2 x3 that satisfy the
following relations
What would you say if you came in and
you didn't know what kind of lecture
this is? What's the lecture course? It's
quantum mechanics, right? Well, the
little eyes is missing because were the
real numbers. You can insert them, you
get minuses and so on. But this is of
course the angular momentum algebra or
the rotation algebra. Anyway, this
algebra,
this L that you get as the span of these
three, I didn't tell you concretely how
they look like, but say you have such
the span of these three
together with the commutator from there.
So assume I can give you three such this
guy is usually called SO3.
There is no metric to be seen anywhere.
smooth manifold and by some in some way
I give you three vector fields that have
these commutation relations and now I
give them to you indeed
you can have x1 equals minus cossine
theta I have to quickly look minus sin 5
dy d theta
minus cos
theta cos 5 d by dy I think that's right
yes quotent sorry
uh x2 is cosi
d by d theta minus quotangent theta sin
fi d by d and the third one x3 is d by d
uh where I now say this is at the point
p I give you the thing at the point p
this is five of P. This is PH of P. This
is theta of P. Theta of P.
Phi of P.
Okay? Because I need numbers there. But
this is just d by d theta. This is this.
And um instead of writing a chart, the
coordinate maps x1 and x2, I write them
more intuitively as maps theta and phi.
But so if you're at a point, phi of p is
the the value of phi and so on. I give
you these three vector fields. This has
nothing to do with metrics. Has nothing
to do with inner product. These are
three vector fields given in a
particular chart on the S2. You can
verify you plug this in and they satisfy
these commutation relations. So the
remarkable thing is that
on the I write merely smooth by merely I
mean there is no additional structure on
the merely smooth manifold S2O standard
with a smooth atlas
this is defined so we have something we
would immediately call an SO3 and that's
what you do and actually the combination
of these linear combinations on the
right hand side are of
these guys here for very special
structure coefficients you recognize in
certain bases and so on you recognize
what algebra you have. So we have a way
to talk about rotation generators namely
these vector fields and the flows of
course take you like this or take you
like that
as a threedimensional rotation algebra.
So now we have this no metric there yet.
Fifth symmetry.
Now we're going to use this in order to
define the symmetry of a metric.
definition
an S dimensional
le subal algebra
L
like this
um describes
or is said
to describe
let's say to be a symmetry
to be a symmetry
of a metric tensor field.
So a metric G and to be very precise a
metric tensor field
G. That's what we're after, right? We
want to classify the round metric on the
sphere as SO3 symmetric but the potato
metric we don't want to classify such
does s dimensional le subal algebra is
set to be a symmetry of a metric tensor
field G
if well if what well what do we have if
for every vector x no vector field x h
vector field
if for every vector field that lies in
the subal algebra. So not only x1, x2,
x3, but anything in the span of the
three, but in the real span, not in the
C infinity span, in the real span. If
for every vector field in the real span
here in this L,
what is true? Well, you have a vector
field
X. Now if it is complete and the um
dirty truth not the dirty truth is the
beautiful truth but I'm not telling you
in detail this is only the lee algebra
to a lee group. A lee group itself is a
manifold with a group structure. The lee
algebra is the set of left invariant
vector fields on there which can be
pulled back to the unit to the tangent
at the identity element of that group
blah blah blah blah blah. The point is
you can show that every left invariant
vector field on a le group is complete
but then you act with this on a manifold
and you get the vector field like this
on the manifold where you see the
algebra mirrored that's the mirrored
algebra on the manifold. So this
background information and you can show
that these are always complete. So I
haven't shown to you and you cannot
comprehend with the material we did but
the guarantee is these vector fields are
complete. Okay. Now you take any vector
field from here they're complete because
they're complete you can look at the
flow
right and but now you want to look at
the metric
after you flew along
that means you have to push forward
the arguments of the metric
and if You compare this
to not having pushed it forward. You ask
the question if I push forward. Sorry.
So this is the hx
hx
lambda and after I did that I have a map
from m to m. So it's hx
lambda and then I use the push forward
and I require
that if I push this forward and this
left hand side could also be written as
the pull back of the metric
okay because it's on the same manifold
these can be the same vectors and this
is new this is the real requirement
right I mean maybe I shouldn't write
this to not confuse you the real
requirement is that this equal sign
hold. So you go forward and you look
elsewhere and if the result doesn't
differ from before how it looked before.
If you flew against a vector field from
this subal algebra
then apparently something has not
changed. Well the metric hasn't changed.
If this is satisfied this is a
condition. If this is satisfied then we
say this sub algebra describes the
symmetry of the metric.
Yes.
For all lambda. Yes, please. That's um
of course if for all lambda in the real
numbers and because it's completed
exist. Thank you very much. Yes. If for
no matter how far I push it, this is
true. And um yes dimensional. What does
the number mean here? I love
it has it's a finite dimensional.
You're right. The the s itself didn't
enter this definition but um I take a
finite dimensionally sub algebra.
Okay. So obviously having chosen this on
the sphere and covering most of the
sphere I mean this is only on this theta
5 chart you know and there's a set of
measure zero take well measure I
shouldn't say that there's a set taken
out but almost the entire sphere is
covered by this of course if you want to
do this very properly you have to choose
a second chart provide the same vector
fields in the other chart only in the in
the overlap region there must be
compatibility and so on on the S2 with
this set or an extension of the set of
vector fields you can check for
rotational symmetry or not of any given
metric. Now I could ask you other
questions. Well, what about not
rotational symmetry, but what about you
have an ellypoid metric, but the
ellipsoid if you look from one of the is
elongated like this, but if you look
from above, it looks like a circle.
That's special because two of the axes
of the ellipsoid are then the same. A
equals b, but the c- axis is longer.
Okay? Then you will only have symmetry
around one
in one direction intuitively, right?
cylindrical symmetry or something like
this. Well, that would reduce this
algebra to just the last field for
instance if you choose it cleverly.
Okay. And that would then be a
cylindrical symmetry. There would be a
one-dimensional
um le subal algebra. So then the
ellipsoid with a equals b axis and c-
axis different would then be only under
this one dimensional which is then very
trivial because the structure
coefficients all vanish and so on only
under this one dimensional uh uh uh
subal algebra will be uh uh a symmetry
right
and so the ellipsoid is not an SO3 but
it's just an well whatever this is SO1
or whatn not it's just a symmetry like
this yes
Yes.
It is.
Ah, no. I made it. Okay. I I am sorry.
I'm sorry. The the X is right because
it's the X from the algebra. I'm very
sorry. This is was a very silly mistake.
And this is any vector field A. any
vector or any vector B and this is AB.
So the X is the one from the algebra and
here you act on vector fields. I I'm
sorry that was very silly. So um maybe
in the in another formulation that
doesn't use these guys is better is if I
take for any lambda the pullback of this
defined on the metric which is
essentially this induced metric I said
before right you see that this is the
definition for um that this equals the
metric
okay
and then you have to be careful at what
point no I think this is right like this
yes can
Yes.
Um, you may mean something like
like this.
No, the left side I I I would like to
understand as defined by this. So I
could say you have a map from five.
Okay, let let's figure it out. Maybe
you're right. Okay, so you have a map
five from M to M and um you would like
to you know the pull back of a co-
vector. Now I define the pullback of a
metric of a 02 tensor. I define it by
acting
on vectors A and B.
Okay. And I say this is supposed to be G
of the push forward of the A and the
push forward of the B.
That's what I do. So that means this
left hand side is this
and this is evaluated on two vectors and
this is without evaluating. Maybe it's a
clearer statement
because up here is of course true for
any AB.
Well, you better choose them from the
same point. From the same point and so
on. Okay.
Yes. That's also an isometry. No. Yes.
That's that's what's called an isometry.
Yes. is set to be.
Yes, this this this this particular map
hx lambda is called an isometry here and
here we have a one parameter family of
isometries
generated from each vector field in this
L. Okay. Yes. So what you're basically
doing here is you're extending each X
lambda to 10. Yes. Yes. That's right.
That's right. Yeah. Yeah. That's right.
That's right. So this is a definition
here. this left this is definition. Yes.
Okay. So um uh so we have that and um
yeah so the example is as I said
if you take the S2 you can take it like
this or you can think of it like
like this. Uh but this is just in both
cases as a smooth manifold. It's the s2
right and on the s2 I have vector fields
for instance uh this d by d51
which might look like this. The others
look similar but around intuitively
speaking other axes of the ambient space
but we're not talking about an ambient
space. Here you also have this vector
field right it's just longer like this
and so on. But now if you put the metric
on it. So if you put here uh the metric
round and here you put the metric G
ellipsoid
right then you will realize so this is
just one of the vector fields from from
from in there um you will in this
particular case uh if from looking from
above it doesn't look like a sphere but
it has a not b c for its axis in this
embedding
um then this one will be s3 symmetric in
the sense we
we described in this rule not be SO3
symmetric.
Okay, that's it.
So I mean this seems a lot of work for
some very small statements but the key
point is this is of direct application
to space-time physics because later on
in spacetime we'll have a metric of
Lorenzian spacetime okay and there will
be the question what is a spherically
symmetric situation and then you will
use exactly those guys and you will
apply them to the four-dimensional
metric and you will um be able to judge
that.
So please one these two floor please.
So one last uh short section is uh six
lee derivatives.
So we agree that this may be true and
may be geometrically intuitive but it's
a mess to check something like this
because you have to check for all lambda
and for all vector fields and so on.
This is not easily checked. This is very
intuitively defined but not easily
checked. Now the le derivative makes
checking for symmetries
child's play. That's the uh the
important thing about the lead
derivatives.
So um it's obvious
it's obvious that if you take X from
this symmetry algebra from this L from
it le sub algebra
and you look at
exactly what I wrote down here you look
at the pull back of the metric under
this
flow field
the pull pull back the metric. Okay? And
you subtract from it the metric.
We know that this is zero, right? If
this is a symmetry, we know it's zero.
But before I do this, I can divide by
lambda. Why wouldn't I? It would still
remain zero.
And I could take the limit lambda goes
to zero. It will still say stay zero.
It's obvious that if
this is zero then L is a symmetry
of the metric as we just defined it.
Right? I just rewrote this and divided
by lambda and took a limit.
Now this left hand side
has a short name L subx on G.
And one says it's the le derivative
of a metric with respect to a vector
field. Namely, a vector field I had to
choose from this L. Well,
you should say if for all such L this is
true, then L is a symmetry. Now it's
statement is correct.
Now this doesn't help you much because
you say okay you added insult to injury
uh this was already difficult to
calculate now you want us to take the uh
uh diff differential quotient here but
the point is it can be shown that this
is just a special it wouldn't deserve
the symbol if there was more behind it.
It can be shown
that this is precisely
the so-called
le derivative
of the metric with respect to the vector
or now it comes vector field
and it's important that it says vector
field and this le derivative
is a structure that's worth exploring in
its own right and we do it by a very
quick definition
and the rest you know how to do because
you have experience with the coariant
derivative. It works totally differently
but the proofs are very similar
definition
a le derivative
and I already said a but that's
absolutely wrong. It's the lead
derivative because there's only one such
the lead derivative curly L
on a smooth manifold
M O A and you ask do we need extra
structure like for the coariant
derivative? No. No. If you have a smooth
manifold the le derivative is already
defined in terms of the smooth
structure. It's fantastic object. Okay.
And we rely we need to rely on it being
defined already on a smooth manifold
from our philosophy. The lead derivative
L on a smooth manifold
um sends
a pair
namely of a vector field that's very
important of a vector field X and a PQ
tensor field
T
2 A the result is again a PQ tensor
field. So it's sounds exactly like for
the coariant derivative such that now I
require such that first the le
derivative acting on a function acts
like the uh vector field on the function
say oh it looks exactly like for the
coariant derivative now I make a second
demand which I don't write down yet a
third demand is that the lead derivative
acting on the sum of two vectors is the
lead derivative derivative of the first
vector plus the derivative of the second
vector a tensor excuse me tensor sum of
two tensors and of course they must be
of the same balance otherwise this
doesn't make sense
we have fourth that the derivative
acting on a tensor that has already been
applied to something so I write it down
for a one one tensor for example like I
did for the le derivative and you can
extend to any This is the le derivative
of the tensor itself evaluated at omega
y plus the le derivative uh plus the
tensor of the le derivative of omega
comma y plus the tensor of omega the
derivative of y. So this is again the
lightnits rule and similarly
similarly for
any
other valance
of t. Now this was the example for t
equals a 1 one tensor.
Now
fifth I mean this is all like the
coariant derivative. If you say this is
going wrong because we know for the
coariant derivative we urgently need
extra structure to have it right there's
some remaining freedom. So it looks like
how is this going to be better? Well
here we make a weaker even requirement
which means it's even worse. We're even
less restricted. The weaker requirement
is that in the lower slot
the thing is additive.
But do you remember that for the coarent
derivative required that if I multiply
by a smooth function that the smooth
function jumps out. I'm not even
requiring this. So, so far I'm weaker
than the coarian derivative which means
I have potentially more freedom still
than for the coarian derivative and for
the coariant derivative I had to put
extra structure to fix the freedom.
So it must really be number two here
that lets us do the whole thing
without adding additional structure. Is
that clear?
Number two says the le derivative of a
vector field y in the direction of a
vector field x is the commutator of x
and y.
That fixes all.
That fixes all. And please note this
last one and this one I have here an x.
The x is in here. And maybe you remember
we once had opportunity when we showed
the C infinity linearity of the torsion
to have an F in here and you saw we can
pull it out but at the cost of an extra
term. We couldn't require this and C
infinity linearity.
That is why we didn't require C infinity
linearity which makes it a weaker
system. But this is very strong and this
fixes it all and you need no additional
structure. You say why didn't you define
this thing before the coariant
derivative? We need this additional
structure. You have a derivative and
it's a directional derivative of tensor
fields that doesn't need additional
structure. Why? Well, it's kind of
cheating because it pulls it sucks in
the information of how the vector field
x behaves away from the point where you
do the derivative.
Yeah, you want to calculate the
derivative at a point,
but it doesn't suffice to prescribe the
value of the vector field X at that
point to calculate this guy. You need
the whole information about how the
vector field behaves in the neighborhood
in order to make the flow. The flow
pushes you forward and so on in order to
calculate this. And this is reflected in
this not being C infinity linear. If it
was C infinity linear here that you
could at a point you could change by a
scalar by a number because a function at
a point is a number but you could in the
neighborhood you could change in many
different ways but the result will feel
it other than the number at the point it
will feel it by the extra term. Okay. So
this is not as good as a derivative as
the coariant derivative.
Well it doesn't no not as good
derivative is a nonsense statement. The
point is um this guy is C infinity M
linear in the lower slot
and this guy is not.
That's the difference. And we needed for
what we wanted to do. We want a C
infinity linear object here. And this
one came up by our considerations of
symmetry and things don't change along
flows and so on. So there are vector
fields provided
and there was a question. Yes, there we
do not require X to be a complete vector
field. No, it just needs to be a vector
field in a neighborhood of the point
where you evaluate. So if you write it
like this, it needs to be no no complete
um because there there
that's true. But um uh if you have a
vector field you can actually make it
complete in a compact neighborhood. So
if you have a compact neighborhood. Yes.
Okay. Okay. So we um
observe or we have the
observe
and this observation is really just a
five minute calculation along the lines.
It may be a very good exercise because
some examiner might get the idea to set
this as an examination task. Okay.
Show that if you act on a vector field
with the le derivative, the result will
be a vector field and it will have an i
component in a chart. So consider a
chart ux and then the examiner might
expect you writing down that the xm in
this chart by dxm may act on the i
component of y expanded in the same
chart um minus very important now comes
a minus here
minus uh
x and now we act with d by dx
on x and we have a y in the game. Now
the x carries the i. This acts on there.
There's an s here and there is an s
there. And there you see again what I
mean in the covariant derivative
compare. In the coariant derivative
we had xm d by dxm
yi. Oh. Because up to this point the
coariant derivative doesn't differ.
But then the coariant derivative
required a plus here. This one requires
a minus. And the coariant derivative
also had the x there and had the y
there.
But in a slightly different manner
because there was extra structure. The i
came from there, the m here and the s
there. And you see because we had the
extra structure we could I mean this is
now a posteriori
talk right? I interpret it like this
because we have the extra structure. We
do not need the derivative of the vector
field X that's down here. Therefore,
this whole thing is C infinity linear in
X. Whereas here, we don't have extra
structure. We do it all by ourselves.
But then we need to look at the
derivative of the components. But the
derivative always looks a little bit
left and right how the field looks like.
Right? So you see this is my statement
that we pay for we pay a price for not
imposing extra structure. The price is
we need to prescribe a vector field X
not only a vector at a point. Okay
anyway that's this and um in general
it looks like this. to say the le
derivative lx of a 1 one tensor has iig
j is of course xm d by dxm acting on tig
j as functions. Okay, now it comes for
any index up what was the rule for the
coariant derivative? It was a plus. For
any index up, it was a plus. Well, for
the lead derivative, it's the opposite.
It's a minus. It's a minus. Um, and then
you do exactly what is done there as D
by D X um
X uh what do I get? I uh X S Y
S
Right? And then for any sorry not ys
nonsense it's a t and I replace the i
index. So there's an s here and a j
there. And then comes a plus.
Then comes a plus for an index down. So
it's exactly the opposite to the
coariant derivative. This is dxi by d.
No, it's not dxi. Ha. Here you go. Now
it's the s up. It's the dxj down. It's
the ti up and the s down. here you
should study this. So anyway that's the
result. Uh and it may be a good idea to
invest the five minutes to derive this
result.
But now you see you can certainly do it.
Our application is the following.
I didn't prove to you
that if G is a 02 tensor that this
definition reproduces this but one can I
spare you that you need to go to
specially adapted charts and argue and D
I spare you that you just trust me you
need to trust me anyway so please trust
me here application is that lxg
can be very easily calculated it looks
exactly like is only that the indices on
the G are always down and so there are
two minuses I know so there are two
pluses instead of a minus and a plus
okay this is particularly simple to
calculate in a chart right it's very
simple to calculate so it's very easy to
calculate this
well here this is the formula from the
below formula
similar
to the one
above.
Well, it's on the blackboard below, but
in the logic above. Okay. And so it
follows it's very easy to check
whether
a metric
features a symmetry.
And conversely, you can say I take the
most general metric, I impose the
symmetry and I learn how it restricts my
the components of my metric in that
coordinate system and then you can use
this as an unzots in the Einstein
equations with many components already
zero.
Textbooks often in general relativity
say let's make the following unzat for a
spherically symmetric metric then
follows a lot of handwaving.
No handwaving on earth can replace this.
Okay.
So you need to say what your symmetry
algebra is that you want to have
implemented.
So this concludes uh this part and then
uh we reconvene at after questions we
reconvene at the quarter past and we
discuss the final completion of our
analysis lift from charts to manifolds.
We discuss how to do integration on
manifolds and that will also be urgently
needed in order not to have the troubles
that Einstein had in setting up his
field equations but to do it the Hilbert
way. Uh that will follow then next
Monday. But first we take questions.
with the derivative you say it's obvious
one direction obvious
okay so you say if it's a symmetry is
that well if I define a symmetry as this
is the case if and only if well that
that definition of symmetry was an if
and only if because it's a definition
and well the statement was before I made
the statement this thing is zero now you
think this could change.
You think the change could not be there?
You just integrate. Yeah. Yeah.
Another question. Does subtraction and
division it happens within real numbers?
No. Here.
No. This is okay. So this minus is the
plus on the space of 02 tensors.
Okay. And that division is the s
multiplication
on the space of 02 tensors.
I mean it's just in each case the the uh
the additive and the multiplicative
inverse
right
could you explain again
explain it oh I didn't derive it I no
sorry I didn't I said observe it takes
five minutes to observe
yeah no I I wrote this from from memory
so this should give you an indication
that you need to know it by memory.
Okay. Pardon me. Wouldn't that be the
commutator?
The com that is the commutator, right?
So this is the commutator. Yes. Yes.
Well, if you want to calculate this from
here, that's the commutator. It becomes
more interesting if you start applying
it to co- vector fields and you need to
use the lap rule one or you need to
apply it to here then you need to use
the lap rule twice. Okay? And then then
you get this. I didn't show this. This
was the idea. uh start with the axioms
and of course starting from here and
here that's what you already know
explicitly and the rest is application
of the rules. Yes. Does this also mean
that given a set of
symmetry?
Yes, you can give other symmetries.
Yes, you can imagine any uh it's not
always easy to read off or to identify
the symmetry by the structure constants.
For instance, the translation group has
all vanishing structure constants. It's
no longer a semi-simple algebra. I said
group algebra. It's no longer
semi-imple. Um but the basic idea is if
physically you have an idea what you
mean by your vector fields whether
they're commutated as zero or not you
just implement them and you say I
require invariance under this for
example in cosmology later on we'll have
a fourdimensional spacetime and I will
require that there be a vector field
like this and like this and in the third
direction and then there's fourth
directions also there and that under
these three that these three bases of
this L and further this one this one and
that on and if they're all together
required to be there that will give you
a a space-time metric that's spatially
whatever that means there's no metric
yet so we don't have spatial that's all
works out um but we have intuitively
three-dimensional homogenity and it
isotropy and that's the cosmological
symmetries so you make a
sixthdimensional
uh symmetry algebra you you require in
order to do uh cosmology ology. If you
say at large scales you want to have
this kind of uh idealized situation in
all directions it looks the same and at
every point of the universe none is
preferred and then you go with this into
the Einstein. So you can make big
symmetry algebra smaller symmetry
algebbras and so on. Yes. And and you
you can use your intuition of what you
mean by the but the algebra is more
fundamental than maybe the group it came
from and how you defined the group for
this application.
Okay.
It will hopefully become even clearer in
the tutorials this afternoon.
There no further questions. Let's
reconvene at the quarter pass, please.